As we age, we usually lose the limits of hearing
So, how many of the following sounds can you hear?
How old are your ears?
Well, if you can hear the frequency of 8000 Hertz, you are certainly alive and not hearing impaired.
But, to keep raising frequency.
How far have you been able to hear? (Uploading video via YouTube is not at this frequency).
If you can hear all those frequencies, you are probably under 20 years of age.
But this will not last forever.
Unlike other organs such as liver or skin.
The inner ear does not have the ability to regenerate.
In your ear thousands of small neurons are called "hair cells".
These cells are responsible for capturing different frequencies and sending a signal to the brain
They are treated, but as you age your constant exposure to noise and loud sounds
May interrupt, discourage and destroy these cells
So, why lose the ability to hear high frequencies first?
It turned out that the hairs tuned to the high tones are the first to face sound waves.
As a result, they are more stressed and tend to spoil early.
So the older you get, the weaker your hearing of high tones.
Do you have an urgent question that you need to answer? Ask in comments or on Facebook and Twitter
Participate in the channel for more scientific sections weekly!